welcome everyone to dc thursdays
i'm pete soderling i am your guide
through the wild wild west
of the changing data ecosystem
and as you know we bring you an amazing
guest every week
uh typically it's a senior engineer
who's been involved in the data world
for a long time
or the leader of an open source project
or the founder of a data company
uh today we're lucky to have all three
and so
i'm uh super excited to welcome
shashanka das to the program
here pete yeah thanks for for making
time to
join us in your busy schedule i just
want to list a couple of your
qualifications in case people aren't
familiar
with who you are but shashanka is the
founder and cto
of a brand new company called ackeral
data
which is behind linkedin's data hub
metadata project
and before acryl shashanka was at
linkedin itself
for almost 11 years as a principal staff
software engineer
where he presided over many of the most
important linkedin data projects over
those years
shashank you've also been an apache pmc
member
principal engineer at yahoo and before
that you're also an application
architect
at paypal finally you've received your
phd in computer science from ucla so
um with all of those amazing credentials
behind you i just want to welcome you
again
uh super glad to be here pete and really
glad
to see the kind of uh work you're doing
for the data engineering community i
think it's been
fascinating to see this community come
together and i think it really deserves
this kind of a home so
oh thanks well it's uh it's really been
a pleasure
um so i want to start with your
schooling because
your your phd thesis was in a pretty
interesting topic
in peer-to-peer networking as i recall
i'm curious how did this prepare you for
a career
in data in tech well
i didn't know it quite back then to be
honest you know i was
following um the shiny problems in the
space
and you know at that time networking
research was
really hot and uh kind of peer-to-peer
movement was taking off and you know my
i was part of the network research lab
at ucla
and uh you know for people in the know
that
has a internet folklore it was part of
the birth of the internet the first
link on the internet was set up between
ucla and berkeley
um and so it was just an amazing place
to be i did my research in peer-to-peer
networks
in kind of the hybrid wired wireless and
vehicular network space
um at that time we were poor grad
students you know downloading stuff off
of the internet and the bittorrent
protocol was a huge rage
um you know on dial-up bittorrent was
amazing
and i did a lot of interesting research
on how one could use
or extend the bittorrent protocol to
accelerate
content downloading on the internet if
for example you're in a car
and you've got brief periods of
connectivity to the internet like
you're passing through a wi-fi zone and
you've got the sudden burst of
connectivity
what can you download but then later on
as you're on i-5
you know which is this big freeway
connecting south california with north
california
you have these long periods of
disconnected operations
so you can use the network of cars
around you to kind of share content with
each other
and we came up with these amazing
algorithms for extending bittorrent to
support peer-to-peer broadcast
got a best paper award as well but of
course all of this was
novel fantasy kind of work and it was
all appended by
you know the iphone and the arrival of
2g because
we had never anticipated that the last
mile connectivity problem to the person
would be solved so simply we were all
thinking about
you know complex ways to get data to the
person
through you know hotspots and then
peer-to-peer communication
but i think some of that work in
vehicular networks did get used and is
kind of
starting to form the backbone of some of
the work that is coming out
um among like car to car networks and
things like that
so i think the research lives on but
i've not been connected to it in the
past
as i look back at you know this concept
of how did that prepare me for
what i'm doing right now one thing i've
definitely seen is
this exposure to the intersection of
real-world applications
and um distributed systems and protocols
was kind of baked into
that early research that i did even
though we were kind of making up the
applications a little bit
but i do see a lot of networking folks
ending up in the distributed systems and
data space
and we end up doing quite well because
you know dealing with message loss
and uh split brain scenarios is kind of
baked into our dna
in terms of how all of the protocols and
the algorithms work
so we end up doing reasonably well and
distributed systems problems
got it so so you took that experience
and ended up at paypal
um like what what's the what's the brief
version of that story of your career
oh that was uh quite interesting because
my first real world experience for that
software engineering experience was at
paypal and here i am you know with my
big fat phd degree
and the first bug that was assigned to
me
was not about distributed systems it
wasn't about lowering page latencies
it was about a unicode character on the
paypal china web page
that wasn't rendering quite right and
you know i didn't know unicode
like i had gone through an entire
education and i did not know what
unicode was so
it was quite interesting to say see what
a true software project
ends up being all the way from data to
the ux of how you actually explain it to
a human
and i just had an amazing education
actually of software engineering
at paypal how do you plan a project how
do you do bug tracking how do you do
software versioning nothing in grad
school like prepared me for any of that
stuff and it was just
a great educational experience i would
say that that first job even though it
wasn't
technically the first you know few
months i wasn't doing distributive
systems at all
but then later on you know it i did get
to do some hard
meaty problems that was fun i like your
story um from those days that
um we discussed briefly previously about
re-implementing the back button maybe
you can tell us about that
yeah quickly so you know see
paypal was a c plus web app and
it was essentially stateless in the
sense that
all the state was sent back to the
user's cookie
um this was before you know ajax was a
thing and
even for people who are old enough to
remember ajax and
now it's single page apps are everywhere
right
i was part of a small team that
implemented the back button for paypal
this was like the biggest reason for
people failing to complete payments as
they were going through like an ebay
checkout
uh they would essentially fill out some
form and then be like i don't think i
want to use that payment method and hit
the back button
you lost everything or you actually get
that dreaded would you like to
resubmit this form button and you go i
don't know what i'm gonna do here so you
just
abort right and so we ended up building
a key value store
um to hold session state
and it was actually my first real world
exporter to a dag now that i look back
at it because
the the ce plus plus web app was
actually
uh there was a dag specification that
would describe how page transitions
should work
and how you carry state across those
page transitions
and so we built a key value store and
this is before memcache even was a thing
to enable bi-directional transitions
as you move forward and backwards on
your personal dag
that we had provisioned for you as you
go through your experience it was just
fascinating building a real world
distributed systems
thing and then making and then seeing
the impact of that once we launched it
it was a huge success
well um those are some good good
examples of um
sort of colliding from you know your
your immediate educational experience um
into
the real world of software engineering
so so after that
um you ended up at yahoo um talked to us
about that
that time because those were the days
when yahoo was essentially like the only
big data game in town they were they had
the best engineers
um they were producing the best open
source um
obviously you know hive and other hadoop
and other tools like came out of yahoo
from that era talk to us a little bit
about that that's right
um i actually didn't work on the data
side of yahoo as much
as the system's infraside so i was hired
to actually
work on the ad systems um that display
ad systems
that yahoo had running in the back they
had recently acquired a company called
write media
this was like one of the foundational
companies
for the ad space because they had along
with doubleclick had mainstreamed the
concept of ad exchanges
ad exchanges were a very novel thing and
then they were just going mainstream at
the time i joined yahoo
and i worked on scaling this ad matching
algorithm
that was struggling to keep pace with
the growing demand
um and made it go from like a single
node
uh this graph algorithm to a distributed
uh graph algorithm for candidate ranking
and matching
and again distributed systems like kind
of really amped up on that
uh experience and i was working closely
with the data team there
to figure out how to get indexes built
offline and then shipped online so that
we could
uh run those ad matching uh
algorithms in like the low milliseconds
100 milliseconds was our budget
and as we were doing this a new kind of
innovative thing
got added to the list of problems we
needed to solve and that was
real-time bidding so it wasn't enough to
just
match ads inside the data center
but we had to make calls outside the
data center to third-party
uh advertisers and think of it like kind
of like the equivalent of high frequency
trading for ads
where we were actually literally
thinking about where are these partners
located what does the
uh speed look like for getting to those
data centers and back so that we can get
back a bit within 150 milliseconds so it
was just
uh pretty much uh hardcore engineering
and
getting latencies down to where we
needed them to be so
really great education and application
of uh distributed systems work
but no data yet got it well there's so
much rigor that goes into these
um real-time bid buy types of systems
and i saw this over the years in new
york city where
um you know maybe new york doesn't have
the same type of pedigree
as the bay area when it comes to certain
kinds of infrastructure
but there's this whole massive um
community of finance engineers who have
been building exactly these high
frequency trading systems for wall
street and
the rigor that came out of that
experience
um was obvious and of course um both
write media and
uh doubleclick um well
write media anyway sort of being started
in new york city double click as well
actually
um so it's not um a surprise to me that
um those two companies actually happen
to materialize in new york because
they were so close to that financial
ecosystem and absolutely that talent
pool that actually knew how to build
those those challenging systems at the
time
yeah yeah and i actually have uh met a
lot of
folks in the financial domain who built
these systems
and in many cases they built them like
better
they like the latencies over there were
even better than
the agencies we were dealing with so
absolutely right
yeah very very interesting um pocket of
of engineering
so um so we're gonna like get into your
linkedin experience
next um i wanna remind the audience that
if they have questions for you they're
they're free to drop them in the chat
and we'll do our best to get to them
uh as time permits but so um shashanka
you you left
yahoo and ended up at linkedin this must
have been
um 2010 ish
yeah yeah it feels like just a few years
ago but it actually was a decade ago
and linkedin was a small company at the
time smallish
company at the time of how many people
do you recall
were on the engineering team or or
company wide when you joined
roughly um engineering i remember we
were about 200
strong we were still having you know our
our all hands uh would still happen in
the
the kitchen that was upstairs um we were
still
able to do like a engineering wide
lunge that was brought in from a you
know catering
and we were all kind of lining up and uh
you know getting our pizzas or sometimes
uh you know sag paneer or whatever was
on the menu
but yeah it was fun times very small
one of the things that i really like
about linkedin is how
much of that initial dna still
is at the at linkedin actually a lot of
the leaders
who at that time were engineers are now
like leaders of
extremely large systems teams
and they really kept that culture still
around where
linkedin still feels small because
everyone kind of
has kept context going and has kept kind
of that culture
going although you know as you know very
well lots of
uh people have gone on to do great and
amazing things
for sure yeah there's uh amazing folks
that you had the chance to work with um
j crabs dj patil um we can't name them
all of course
um sam shaw um others
uh martin klopman even if i'm not
mistaken
yeah yeah absolutely that was i would
say
um it seems like pretty much all of the
best people in data
simultaneously were kind of at linkedin
at the same time
um we there was a lot of like the
reading groups
we were deciding where stream processing
should go
um how should we think about it i
remember having chats with jay about
you know the table stream duality uh
before kind of he wrote his seminal blog
post when martin was doing his research
on um like the systems before he wrote
his iconic book
um we were white boarding on how databus
was designed and
how kafka was slightly different dj of
course is a legend
right sam and i actually we caught up
recently and we were discussing how
we tried to put in practice uh kind of
data governance practices
um and uh in and how data modeling was
done at linkedin and how we would
see kind of contracts being created
between data producers and consumers and
how
schemas are one way to do it but you
actually need to do something more to
educate people to write good schemas in
the first place and how do you
scale that process it's kind of an
interesting thing um
so what what what was the state of data
at linkedin um at that time maybe talk
us through
um the sort of the state of the union
and then some of the the early key
projects that you
implemented because i know you had
visibility across essentially
all the data infrastructure at linkedin
um you know starting
starting from then and up until very
recently
yeah yeah i think when i started
we had a couple of burning problems one
was our tracking system
was completely broken and jay was
essentially working on kafka
the other problem we had was
storage so our we were you know
reaching the limits of what we could
accomplish with uh oracle
not because oracle is bad but i think
just because
you know web scale systems need slightly
different capabilities we needed
a lot more and a lot more flexibility
so we ended up building um first
designing
deciding then designing and then
building espresso
it was obviously fueled over lots of
caffeine but
uh it ended up being a pretty
important system for linkedin uh it now
is uh the persistent storage system for
pretty much
every linkedin page that you might visit
like your profile
isn't espresso your inbox is in espresso
and it was kind of an ambitious project
you know building a source of truth
system
so we kind of attracted a lot of good
talent built out a great team and then
built out this project over multiple
years and that was kind of one of the
most ambitious things uh linkedin has
done besides you know kafka
and uh our our graph engine there's been
like a lot of big projects that linkedin
has done as far as i
it's one of them i had a uh i had a
front row seat to it i was in there
building kind of the first
version of it demoing it to kevin scott
it was like fantastic times so is is
espresso like a document store like
or are we talking about today it
is
it is it is it is a document oriented uh
transactional store
um it's actually built on top of sharded
mysql so we
did not try to reinvent um how to store
data reliably that's one of the lessons
i've learned uh
building source of truth storage systems
is hard when it comes all the way down
to
like bits and bytes so try to use tech
that's already there and has been
hardened over the years but there's a
lot to build on top right what does
what do schemas look like um how do you
evolve schemas what are the
how do you subscribe one of the things
that linkedin always had
starting even before kafka was the
system called data bus that i also
worked on which was a
change data capture system so linkedin
was always built on this
you you make a write to your primary
data store and then you subscribe to
changes coming out from it and then you
keep your search indexes up to date or
your graph index is up to date
and so databus was kind of that cdc
stream provider
and i think in the open source we
actually open sourced it later as well
it actually did
have a fair amount of adoption but in
the in the modern day i would say
you know kafka has of course supplanted
data bus as kind of a both a cdc
provider
as well as a a really good log system
but then there's also systems like the
bayesium and others that you hear about
that are kind of in the cdc space so
databases
how did databus and kafka sort of emerge
at the same time
um at linkedin how did that occur
so the the lineage of these projects was
uh was orthogonal for a while before
they kind of converged
database started out as um
as a subscription model to the database
without its own persistent log so the
source of truth is outside
the system you've got the commit the
commit happened in the database and
databus is just reflecting that change
and just scaling out that subscription
model but
think of it as a log cache almost a
cache
on top of that subscription whereas
kafka started out
initially with solving the hard problem
of i've got gobs and gobs of
tracking data or event logging data that
i actually need to store somewhere
and then scale out the subscriptions how
do i solve that problem
and if you miss a few it's okay you know
you just have to get
99 point you know large number of nines
but it's okay to lose one or two right
so in fact
uh consistent uh replication and you
know all of that stuff in kafka came
later
whereas in data bus we could relax that
because the source of truth was always
the primary story so as the technologies
evolved
it was quite obvious that kafka should
just take over
the data bus role as well and kind of
solve that commit log problem
it was a much harder lift but actually
when espresso was built and then as it
went through
kind of its next evolution we we did
replace the the replication log of
espresso with kafka and it actually made
kafka much more durable
so after doing kind of my you know
journey in
the storage and streaming infrastructure
space i ended up
as i like to call it following the data
down to kind of the big data side uh
because
it seemed like we had kind of solved
storage we had
solved scalable collection and
subscription
of data but there were bottlenecks just
beyond that horizon
and i ended up you know taking on a role
to
be the tech lead for the big data
platform team and
the first problem i noticed was that
getting data in
to the data lake itself was kind of a
hard problem
we had lots and lots of separate
pipelines that we had built over the
years
and ingestion seemed to have similar
capabilities across all of these
pipelines and yet some of them had audit
some of them did not have audits some of
them
supported schema evolution some of them
didn't it was just
debt by a thousand cuts so out of that
kind of mess emerged the apache goblin
project
and i have spent quite a bit of time in
making that
system kind of work both for small scale
ingestion as well as for large scale
ingestion
that has kind of evolved to becoming our
data i would say data integration and
data life cycle management system
um for all of kind of the data at rest
so it kind of
gets all the data in from apis kafka
all of these big fire hoses of data
using a single
unified framework
lands it into hadoop organizes it
and then supports export also so it
supports
getting this data out of the lake back
into online systems or
back into api uh systems
and more importantly it supports kind of
the data
asset as it moves through its life cycle
inside the lake like uh
you know maybe it lands in avro and then
gets converted into
rk or orc and
as we did our as our cloud migration is
kicking into gear right goblin is a
system that automatically figures out
which data sets need to be provisioned
where and starts
copying them over into azure so building
that
kind of control plane for
governed data movement and then having
um it work end to end in kind of a
holistic way that was
kind of the journey of uh apache goblin
so goblin goblin is quite a mature
project then i guess i'm always a little
surprised that it feels to me like it's
underexposed
based on the power and and um
just sort of the the real world um
battle testing
that it's gone through right like we
have these commercial systems um five
tran or reptilian
or data coral or others
um but it seems like you know there's
been this open source
thing under our nose the whole time i'm
just
wondering if you have any comments on on
why you think
um sort of we're in this situation and
why goblin maybe hasn't been a little
a little more popular or gotten the the
respect that it deserves
um i think it's a combination of a few
factors
one obviously is that
you know anything that has its origins
tied very closely to hadoop
is harder to quickly adopt because you
know
it's going to bring in uh dependencies
on hadoop
and that automatically is like bloats up
your jar by a lot
there's also um so goblin started out as
a map-reduced
job and then over the years it got
better at
supporting lots of different
configuration mechanisms lots of
different
deployment mechanisms and
you know it's it's one thing to to make
a project
work really well at one company
and then make it open source and then
help others who might come around
and ask for help but it's quite another
to truly scale that adoption
and make that final last mile of fit and
finish to make it truly easy to use
truly simple to understand those things
really require
a lot of additional work and it's never
the first thing that you would do if
your
main job is making the data lake at
linkedin work really well
so we've seen a lot of mature companies
actually adopt goblin
um so like big names like paypal
um apple you know samsung they're like a
big name
companies that have adopted goblin and
use it actually in production
but it's it's the the long tail of
adoption
around like small i've got just one data
set over here can i quickly ingest it
uh you might do just fine with the
smaller system and so we see a lot more
it's got accessibility showing up there
got it
um and i think you were gonna you're
gonna step into some of the analytical
stores and analytical lessons of
linkedin as well i heard you i heard
pino sort of escape from your mouse um
before i cut you off so my my apologies
oh no worries i mean pinot was something
that emerged from that same team i
i would say had a sip of you know uh
didn't really
i was involved in some of the designs
but uh i think it's
it's one of those things that
brings to fruition the decoupled
architecture that we had so
one of the things that i've kind of
noticed with how linkedin's
data infrastructure evolved and why it
worked well
was that we always had this dream
at the center of connectivity between
systems
so if for example someone came up with
a new way to do olaf
on data and pinot was an example of that
before that
we had a homegrown search engine that we
were using for primarily
all of our analytics use cases
and you see elasticsearch used a lot in
the in the wild right as uh
you started out with search and
sometimes you use it for analytics
sometimes you use it for both
and pinot's journey was kind of
starting with linkedin initially using a
search style backend for analytics and
then realizing
we can actually do much better by
getting rid of most of the search
baggage
and really building a and a columnar
engine for this and
then the the thing i observed about the
pinot evolution
was that we were able to put it into
production without changing the whole
site
and that i think is really only possible
when you have designed your architecture
in a way that you can
swap in and out components without
having to re
change everything and the fact that your
source of truth store
is producing a stream of events that can
then be subscribed to by your search
index
and then also be subscribed to by your
analytics engine
and so you can kind of have them both
running live for a while before you
decide to cut over some queries from one
to the other
that just gives you a whole level of
flexibility that you don't have
one of the constants i have seen in all
companies is change we're always
swapping out one technology for another
we're always on some
continuous migration from one thing to
another and so having decoupled systems
i think is fundamental
uh if you take a too big of a dependency
on one thing
you're you're dead but it's it's funny
how how
much time and and dependency on
individual
systems sort of inappropriate dependency
in hindsight it takes
for a for an organization to evolve to
the point where they're actually able to
correctly
atomize um and and clearly understand
how to decouple these dependencies right
so obviously
you know you and your team at linkedin
um
were able to step through that over the
years and so
um we're able to come come up with these
these concepts but
it's funny how obvious it is in
hindsight but not obvious when you're
when you're in the forest right
that's true that's true uh one of the
interesting things
uh that happened as part of the
uh unanticipated dependency problems
that we created was
we had gotten good at decoupling data
with you know kafka in the middle and
all of that stuff but
we never got good at decoupling meta
data
until you know we really took a strong
stance about it
so for example when espresso took a
snapshot
it would drop it on to a file system and
then there would be another system that
would go in
and check espresso for the latest schema
and check espresso for the latest table
definitions and then go back into the
file system to see if that all matched
up and it was like just a
hairball of dependencies from this
downstream system going back into this
upstream system
and i was guilty of half of it by the
way right i mean i built
espressos schema registry of sorts and
you know in my wisdom back in the day i
decided to use zookeeper for it
because you know my goal was i needed a
place to store schemas
and i needed the entire cluster to be
able to react
when schemas were added into espresso
and zookeeper fit the build because
it was pretty good you could write to it
and be sure that the data got there
schemas are generally not very large and
the entire cluster could just watch
the zookeeper ensemble and then just
react to changes
but then it got really complicated when
you talked about external
observers so if i'm outside espresso
like i'm a downstream etl consumer
or someone who's not even in the same
data center and i want to
observe if a schema in espresso changed
or what is the latest schema
in espresso for a particular table well
i need to reach in to the
zookeeper instance and get that out and
you know with kafka we had slightly
similar issues not with schema registry
but with
kind of the topic partition registry and
things like that
and so we one thing i noticed was just
over the years we
as system developers we just design
the metadata systems inside these
systems
just right for the system but don't
really think through
the interfaces of metadata for the rest
of the systems to integrate cleanly with
it
i was tapped on the shoulder to lead
gdpr
for linkedin lead meaning be the tech
architect
for it and partner with the legal team
and the product team and kind of figure
out this whole
complex regulation and understand what
it means for us
and one of the first things i realized
was that we actually didn't have a
consistent vocabulary
across these different systems for how
we refer to data sets how we refer to
columns within a data set
you know i had originated the warehouse
project
very poorly named in hindsight at that
time it seemed like the most clever name
we could have
come up with because you know it's the
where and the how of data
it was a search and discovery portal for
um
making it easy for data scientists and
data workers to
quickly see where the data is and for
our warehouse and
um it was kind of a hybrid warehouse
that we were running back in the day
between
hadoop and teradata uh a lot of people
were migrating out of
informatica and microstrategy and they
wanted kind of the same familiarity of
being able to see lineage and being able
to understand where data came from and
so we
built warehouse as kind of a
visualization
plus aggregation of that metadata
but when so this was this is essentially
like your first
data catalog if you will like this yes
this is this is the early days
of building a data catalog at linkedin
that
that supported discovery of so you
basically had data flowing across all
these systems
um you had you had solved a lot of the
streaming and
ingest issues you had solved a lot of
the storage issues you had
um you know loosely coupled your
architecture and made a lot of progress
there
um but now the people in the org um you
know as linkedin was growing massively
they needed to know how to find the data
that they needed to find
um and that was a non non-obvious and
non-trivial
trivial problem yeah yeah i mean
initially i thought it was very trivial
you know just get all the metadata like
just
crawl everything get it in one place put
a
search index on top like problem start
what's so hard about this
uh and so warehouse the first version
was exactly that it was literally and i
call this like the generation one
the first generation of metadata
architectures
uh so warehouse was literally that and
it you know we built it quickly
and we got it out we got some lessons
from it
and then we saw that people weren't
using it enough
i mean like wait why are people not
using this thing we built it it's got a
nice decent search api
and we realized that it's not just
enough to
get all the metadata in one place and
put a search interface on top
you actually have to make sure that this
metadata is
live and it's
now and it's comprehensive yeah
yeah and was this was this a challenge
with the the initial
you mentioned that you had a scraping or
a spidering kind of an architecture um
and i and i hear about a lot of
companies and projects these days that
are sort of adopting a similar
approach right like um let's just scrape
all the
all the metadata and and put it in one
place and then we'll build a data
catalog
on top of it that sounded like that was
that was your approach as well and it
wasn't as successful as you anticipated
and
it's largely because of this do you
attribute that to the freshness
challenges of
these scraping type systems yes
i think it's a good way to kind of
unlock some value and at least get your
basic product hypothesis validated that
people will be interested in this but i
think
to go from interested to using it every
day
and depending on it you need to go from
kind of a periodic scraping approach to
essentially
a continuous live metadata is
part of your operational fabric system
because that means i can go
create a chart somewhere right and then
if i have a question about
this data set that this chart depends on
and who has used it i can go back to the
catalog and i get the information live
as of right now
people can come back to this place and
ask questions like
um is this data set ready um
when was this data set created can i
actually trust this data set based on
when it was last generated how many
records did it have so all of these
so the base signal obviously is getting
all the metadata in one place
and there are if you do a scraping
approach what ends up happening is those
pipelines fail all the time
because it's the same problem as with
data really
uh you know generally
better contracts lead to better outcomes
so if you can actually
take create a contract that a producer
can conform to
and you make that their responsibility
then you have higher likelihood that
they're going to keep that contract
so for example in the case of metadata
it is just
hey espresso every time a new table gets
registered
into your system you need to publish an
event
and that event should contain the table
name the schema
the owners of the table all of this
stuff right and once you kind of
explain this to the espresso team or the
oracle team
dbas and the mysql team people go
okay i can live with that contract
because i know exactly what my
expectations are so we started seeing
kind of this evolution
so in some sense you know as warehouse
evolved to becoming data hub
we kind of went through this uh
decoupling or deconstruction
of that uh metadata platform
into saying let's push responsibility
into
where it belongs data metadata producers
systems that are the source of truth for
metadata should just be responsible for
publishing changes to metadata
when it happens and
what i found interesting was how few
metadata systems are architected
that way to actually emit changes out
when
changes happen like you know the hide
meta store
even the kafka schema registry that was
built at linkedin initially
now thankfully the confluence schema
registry actually does have a change
stream coming out of it but
when the initial customer registry was
built we looked around and said oh
here's an oracle database let's just put
all our
kafka schemas in there and so you don't
have a chain stream coming out of it
it's not easy
and most systems kind of don't do that
so it's
it's always hard to do it but once you
do it then really great things happen
you have a live
schema registry that has a catalog
across
all of your systems and and do you
do you see this as a meaningful paradigm
for other enterprises to follow these
days
i mean i'm curious as to what what your
expert opinion is in terms of
what are the main hurdles and milestones
in an org
starting to to think about metadata this
way and really investing
in that metadata strata in their
data infrastructure that they've
committed to
and as you indicated all the other teams
data teams across the org are committed
to as well to the extent
that they're that they're willing to
write to these contracts um
like talk to us about you know common
sort of failure modes and challenges
um in in getting the org to this level
because it sounds like a
like a holy grail of metadata management
and i think
it makes sense to those of us who have
been in data for a long time but i'm
sure
getting an org to that point um you know
there are some key hurdles um to get
through i'm just curious
as to what you see those being um in the
modern world
um so i think there's there's good news
and bad news in the sense that you know
linkedin was a
very mature
company with a lot of stuff we built
in-house
and so integration with every individual
tool or system was custom
in many cases whereas if you look at a
lot more
of the modern enterprises as they are
starting off
they're consuming off the shelf products
much
more so maybe you're writing all your
code in github
or gitlab and those systems have very
standard
uh ci cd integrations
so it's it's not that hard for you to
say
every time i check in a schema this
thing needs to run
like we are we are in the age where
we are saying data ops git ops you know
these things are becoming
ingrained into the dev life cycle
and so i think especially for modern
enterprises
it should be less problematic
to start embracing some of these
change-oriented metadata
publish capabilities because
the tools and technologies have actually
evolved to support
this kind of continuous build continuous
deployment continuous testing
and you see this with great expectations
as well right like people are
starting to think about testing
code testing data all of that has to
happen
using similar concepts and so metadata
testing metadata publishing can also get
integrated into those same hooks
of course if you drop into an extremely
old system with tons of etl scripts that
have been checked into some old source
repository and you need to crawl all of
them
yes you'll have to do work but i think
um
the enterprise definitely is ready for
metadata management if i were to
kind of uh say that the time for
metadata to take
center stage i think has come and in
some sense the
innovation over the past decade of like
lots of tools and technologies that have
come up like this extreme specialization
that we've created in the data stack
right you no longer have a single
informatica
with a single etl gui to manage
everything because
when you had that and there was one
single transformation tool that could
rule it all
it had lineage inside it and it had
metadata management inside it and you
would say
i got everything i need in this one
place but now we're sort of
deconstructing
that whole ecosystem and saying there is
a special tool for transformation for
analysts and maybe that's dbt
and there might be a separate special
tool for ml practitioners and maybe
that's fight art for tensorflow or
whatever right
and there's a special tool for
visualization and maybe that superset
or looker and we see this repeatedly
each of these tools they have their own
beautiful visualizations of metadata
inside themselves
has an amazing metadata model dvd has
amazing lineage and yet
people do come to data hub and say but i
need to step back
and see kind of the bigger picture end
to end
i've got my dbt lineage and then i want
to see what's the looker dashboard that
it's powering
and then i actually want to go back
upstream and see from the dvt
lineage dvt starts from the warehouse i
want to go one step up
and look at the kafka stream that
actually generated that table and maybe
even one step above to the operational
store
so i think um this diversity of tools
and technologies have kind of
forced the enterprise to say hey we
actually need to take a somewhat
vendor neutral approach to this metadata
management thing
and get something that's outside these
individual tools
so that we can see across
you talked about roadblocks to adoption
uh one of the things i have definitely
seen
is sometimes people think about the
metadata world and get very scared
they basically say hey metadata strategy
is kind of like a big thing
it's an organizational problem and so
you know we are in a little bit of a
mess right now maybe we'll go do
something small over here
let's come back to our metadata strategy
next year
and so one of the failure modes i think
is just waiting too long to get started
because they
feel like they actually have to
completely reimagine the world
before they can do anything about it and
i have seen you know good cases where
that has worked out um like saxo bank
vault these are companies in the data
hub community that have
started on a data mesh journey and they
said hey
we're starting to rethink our data
strategy we have a data mesh journey
that we're starting to plan
out how should we think about the data
discovery or the data catalog or the
metadata problem
and so they're kind of putting the right
practices in place on day one
because for them it is now day one
they're kind of starting a new journey
but there are also other companies
linkedin itself obviously uh
but other companies in our community
like expedia and klarna we're kind of
starting with this journey of let's
first enable discovery
let's first start this organic evolution
from discovery
where you can just drive observability
you can drive productivity
and it's still adding a ton of value
before
you start deepening the seriousness of
metadata and start baking it into data
management baking it into governance use
cases
that requires kind of that broad buy-in
so i think both playbooks have
definitely have seen that play out and
it really depends on where you
are in your data management or data
management metadata management journey
yeah i would say it's never too early to
get started
for sure well i'm i'm sold um it's great
to hear your
your thoughts um you know on the topic
and i know that you're so passionate
about this
um data discovery metadata management
um data like you you just sort of laid
out um
you know the various options um that
we're seeing in
enterprises adopt but but you're so
committed to this you decided to
start a company obviously um around data
hub so congrats on that i know it's
it's a brand new baby company um there's
not much info online yet
you're starting to get get out there
more publicly so it's awesome to
to be able to support you in that um so
so huge congratulations
and tell us about uh about accrual data
and what it's all about
well it's very simple we started out
with this mission of
we want to bring clarity to data and uh
you know the name acryl actually comes
from
uh long story comes from plexiglas which
was you know the material of choice for
last year
because it's transparent and it allows
you to see things clearly
but it also saves you from the germs and
keeps you protected
so plexiglas is actually made of acrylic
which is a compound and acrylic is the
class of compounds
that uh make uh that that kind of
acrylic is a part of so accurate data
is is really transparent our mission is
yes
yes awesome so you know our goal really
in the short term
like and forever is to be growing
the open source community around data
hub so we're committed to
growing it we believe really that the
metadata platform has to be open source
it has to be
amazing it has to be something that you
really want and love
um and so we are actively collaborating
with linkedin and the broader open
source community
on on a pretty exciting roadmap it's
been amazing actually because the
community is very active
they give us a lot of feedback um and
we've
we've grown uh tremendously uh month
over month uh
this last quarter we've grown like 20
percent uh
every every month and our commuter base
has grown quite a bit as well we've
got quite a bit of diversity in our uh
committee base
you had initially asked about goblin one
of the things for example
that goblin really lacks is a python
interface and that actually makes
it inaccessible for a lot of uh
developers in the data world
and so with data hub we actually built
out an ingestion framework and an
emitter framework that is python first
and actually has all of the same apis
that
you expect with a typed java interface
and so that
actually has really energized the
community and we we're seeing a lot of
um a lot of uptake and that's been
exciting where of course you know it's
actual data we're of course
building a hosted version of data hub um
that'll not only be cloud native but
also multi-cloud ready
so that allows us to bring the best of
data hub to any company
you know whether you have the engineers
and you want to stand it up yourself
and you know go to town with it that's
great or if you want us to host it for
you
um then we we're there to help
awesome well that's uh that's that's
super exciting
um how like what sort of involvement are
you looking for
from the community these days um
you know what are the best ways for
folks to to learn more about the data
hub project
um to get in touch with you to be
involved
um like what what sorts of touch points
are there that folks should be aware of
well our superfar is our community and
we totally need lots of love and
inspiration
um we end up we end up
uh living in slack that's that's where
we are
um we're hosted on datahub project dot
io
it's okay sometimes a little hard to
find you can get distracted by finding
datahub.io which is not the same
project so datahub project.io is
is our homepage and we we are on slack
and
talking continuously one of the things
i'm actually really excited about
is the quality of engineers in our
community um
we actually have architects and
engineers and that's like fascinating
because we're not only debugging issues
like hey this doctor container is not
starting up
but we're also talking about data
architecture problems uh we're talking
about data modeling challenges we're
talking about metadata storage
graph indexes and also data mesh ideas
and if you know anything about data mesh
it's like the latest greatest
thing so we're kind of we are sort of in
the middle of it all and it's
quite exciting um we host once a month
town halls
with our community and those have become
kind of like celebrations of what we've
done in the last month we demo the
latest features
and to share adoption journeys uh for
companies that are you know running pocs
and getting successful with
data hub and kind of seeing what those
platform teams face because they're
bringing in data hub into their
companies
and then they're trying to run that
playbook of what does it take to make
the company successful with data hub so
it's fun to run these product ideas and
brainstorming
sessions and figure out how do we make
the community successful with this
product
awesome so great so datahub project
dot io is the is ground zero for
the data hub community online um folks
can
get connected learn about the schedule
on your
on your community meetings um join your
slack
and connect with your community that way
and obviously you are also
at sri shanka on twitter i'm assuming
that folks can
reach out to you there if they have some
questions as well
absolutely absolutely too
happy to respond to dms or
public tweets excellent well
one of the other things uh since you
brought up community one of the other
things
i organized in the community is uh
something called metadata day
we did the first version of it uh last
year
it was a huge success we got like the
big names of metadata folks like joe
hellerstein and natasha noye and
you know all the big projects and the
practitioners together
and it's been great and we're looking to
create more of such events
and actually really energize the
community around
why metadata is a first-class concern
and why people should think seriously
about it
excellent well definitely keep me posted
on the next metadata
metadata day because i want to share
that with our data council community as
well
technically so it's been it's been a
great chat shashanka um
before i let you go i just wanted to ask
you a final question
and um that's what what surprised you
about your work
in the data ecosystem so far
wow that's a tough one what surprised me
well this question surprised me
um
i would say the one thing that surprised
me was
how as i kept even though i've kept
working on different
problems like storage streaming
analytics metadata seems like
at some level the same problems keep
repeating themselves
there are still a few hard problems in
data that are still open
problems really i don't think we found
the answer
for example what is a perfect api for
data
is it sql is it graphql
is it a graph query language which is
different from graphql
how does the search api fit in is it
like an orthogonal thing off to the side
i think that's still a fantastically
hard problem
that keeps coming up every time i design
another api
for data or metadata and really closely
related to that
is what is a perfect modeling language
for data uh is there a perfect modeling
language for data
there's so many options out there and i
don't think there is consensus around
what it is and i would say probably the
hardest one that i've seen again and
again is
everything that lies at the intersection
of systems and people
so organizational collaboration on data
and metadata is
just fascinating and hard and
some of it is culture some of it is
process
some of it is technology and you really
have to figure out how to make all three
work for you
um and so that's why i'm really excited
about actual data because
we're going after some of these hardest
problems with
an amazing metadata platform called data
hub which we're saying
you know enterprises are facing this
existential problem that
they need to create extreme productivity
for their data teams
with you know trusted data and we think
we can solve it using this amazing
metadata based architecture and so
that's why i'm excited but i think the
hardest problems are right there
that's great well some like as you
mentioned a bunch of the problems have
already been solved and
and you know we at data council want to
expose folks to the best of breed
solutions
um to these problems so if they don't go
have to roll their own and re-implement
the wheel metadata management is is
something that i feel like we're in the
early
innings of data discovery etc and so um
we're really excited to have you pushing
the envelope forward in this area
and we look forward to staying in touch
and and seeing how the data hub project
and actual data
develop so um best of luck with that and
keep us posted
cool thanks a lot this is great yeah
thanks
thank you funko all right uh and thanks
to everyone else for
joining us today um we hope that you
enjoyed this episode
uh please make sure and subscribe to the
data council youtube channel hit the
bell
notification so that you get updates
when we go live again in the future
and just as a final announcement our
next dc thursday
will be next week it's on open cloud
lake houses
with ori raphael from upsolver so we
hope that you can join us
then until then um enjoy your your data
plumbing your data pipeline through data
systems
and think about metadata management from
all of us at data council
we'll see you soon